you'll hear lots of people say you have
to use sulfate free shampoo to avoid
damaging or stripping your hair you'll
also hear people say you have to use
sulfates to get your hair clean they are
both wrong almost everyone
misunderstands this fundamental thing
about shampoos and I think it's why so
many people can't find the right
products I'm Michelle of lab muffin
Beauty science chemistry PhD and
cosmetic chemist and person who usually
talks more about skin care science but
we are doing hair today I've been paying
more attention to hair science on the
internet lately and there are so many
completely wrong explanations and strong
opinions and just people yelling at each
other
but because I love pain apparently I am
going to talk about it I'm starting with
sulfate versus sulfate free shampoos
I've talked about it a bit before but
I'm going into more depth because I
think if we really dig into the
chemistry of it a lot of things about
hair start making more sense but before
we talk about sulfates we have to talk
about the state of hair science not just
internet hairstyles but actual academic
hair science it is a mess there are
three big reasons I think there's so
much confusion reason one hair is really
diverse so much more than skin different
hair just does not respond to Hair Care
Products the same way skin care seems
complex but when you break it down it's
actually pretty straightforward maybe
also it seems that way to me because
I've been talking about it for so long
with skin type there's oily and dry and
in between then you have concerns like
Fine Lines pigmentation acne it does
take a while to understand your skin and
find the right products for it I have to
plug my ebook because I keep forgetting
to do that it walks you through that
post process but when it comes down to
it ingredients tend to work pretty
similarly for everyone if you have a
hundred people use glycerin on their
skin you might have 60 people's skin get
more hydrated and improve 20 people's
skin stays around the same and the final
20 might get worse for some reason like
the glycerin helped some other
ingredient penetrate and the skin got
irritated or they have an allergy there
is still complexity but you wouldn't
have like half the people's skin dry out
more but that's kind of how it is with
hair even just with the shape of the
strands you have straight curly a
million different levels and types of
curly kinky tight coils the coils might
be rounder or flatter or a mix and shape
makes a massive difference to how hair
responds to different products variation
in geometric shape is just not something
we have to think about much with skin
take wet versus dry detangling for
example the way water interacts with
hair is weird I'm not going to go into
too much detail here because that's a
whole topic for like five videos but in
short it weakens the bonds gluing the
inside of the hair together which is why
hair gets stretchy when it's wet but it
adds stickiness to the outside of the
hair so hairs stick together more easily
and you need to use more Force to get
the comb through water also raises the
cuticle scales these are the roof tile
looking cells on the surface and that
means they can bash against each other
more and Chip so all of this means it's
less damaging to detangle hair when it's
dry but that's just for straight hair it
is the opposite for curly hair all of
these effects still happen but changing
just the shape of the hair strand that
is enough to change the physics of how
the hair interacts with a comb the
cuticle scale still stand up more the
curly hair is still weaker on the inside
and sticky on the outside the hair is
still more fragile but there are two big
differences first off the hairs stick to
each other less because there is less
alignment or tessellation between curly
hair strands compared to straight hair
it's like how when you cook spaghetti
they stick together much more than where
spiral pasta on top of that the
weakening of the bonds inside the hair
actually makes the curls loosen in shape
a loosical means that geometrically
there's less chance of tangling and
causing damage and breakage so the
change in the physics of how that curl
interacts with the comb that can offset
the damage from manipulating wet fragile
hair and overall you get less breakage
there's a few studies showing this but
where is the line is it better to
detangle say wavy hair when it's wet or
dry what if you use a brush versus a
comb or a different type of brush what
if you detangle it from the bottom up or
just straight from the top what happens
if you partly dry the hair those answers
just don't seem to exist and we are just
talking about water and hair shape we're
not even talking about other ingredients
how often you wash your hair how much
damage you have the type of damage you
have if you bleach or straighten your
hair or how long your hair is or how
oily it is there are a lot of variables
and this kind of overlaps with reason
two hair science is just really smart we
just do not know that much about hair I
used to assume that hair was really
straightforward I mean hair is dead skin
is alive if you're doing tests on hair
strands it should be really easy you
just buy a bunch of hair that is so much
easier than finding volunteers but
because of all this diversity with hair
every experiment you do you just can't
necessarily generalize it to other types
of hair on top of that there are tons of
other variables that make a huge
difference to hair like what humidity
the experiment started and end up with
when I go places with high humidity it
gets a little extra body okay that alone
can massively change the results and we
all live in places with different
humidities and the humidity changes
throughout the day it changes in
different rooms so it isn't like if
every study did experiments at 20
humidity that would solve the problem
hair scientists don't even know the
structure of hair in that much detail
the understanding is still evolving
relatively quickly and there just isn't
that much consistency with terminology
even in the peer-reviewed literature so
for example around the late 90s some
hair scientists just decided half the
protein in hair wouldn't be called
keratin anymore and they have good
reasons for that but not everyone got
the memo or maybe some hair scientist
just didn't agree so you'll still read
things like hair is 80 keratin by mass
even in this paper from 2017 and this
isn't a huge deal here because it is
pretty clear they're using that old
definition but if a paper says we
concluded that this ingredient works on
keratin and hair do they mean keratin or
do they mean keratin
reason three hair products aren't just
about individual ingredients the two
main hair products shampoo and
conditioner the way they work isn't
about the individual ingredients the
overall formulation is really important
and yeah we say that a lot about
skincare but it is even more the case
with hair care and this is Central to
this debate about sulfates and shampoos
sulfates usually refers to sodium lauryl
sulfate and sodium Laurice sulfate these
are two of the cleaning ingredients also
factors that you find in things like
shampoos and cleansers so factors are
special because they have a head that
likes water and a towel that likes oil
as you hopefully know from Life oil and
water don't usually mix so surfactors
can help oil break up and mingle with
water so you can rinse it away and end
up with clean hair or skin the tails are
pretty similar and surfactant so most of
the time we're talking about the hairs
sulfates have sulfate head groups
chemists are not imaginative when it
comes to naming and yes if we compare
sulfates on their own with other
surfactants on their own they have good
cleaning ability but because it's hair
science there is more complexity these
four diagrams show four different ways
that shampoos clean at a microscopic
level each of these diagrams is read
from left to right the pink tadpoles are
the surfactants and you can see that the
surfactants are coordinating to clean
the hair this is called a supermolecular
process where the molecules are
interacting without going through a
chemical reaction it's a bit like
molecular choreography now this isn't
like four separate processes or all four
of these are probably happening on your
hair at the same time to different
extents there are probably still more
mechanisms still to be discovered how
much of these depends on the formula of
the shampoo because the pink table
surfactants won't all be the same
they'll have different Tendencies to
interact in different ways but it also
depends on what sorts of stuff or soils
you're cleaning off because they are
also part of this choreography so for
example if you have bigger Blobs of oil
on your hair then this one is probably
happening more because some of that oil
breaks off multiple times instead of all
of it coming off at once like here but
if you have big particles that don't
break up easily then it might all just
be figure four this one happens more at
highest effect and concentrations and
that is another variable and that's not
just about the concentration of the
surfactants in the formula at the start
of the shampooing process you've just
put the shampoo on your hair it's at
maximum concentration but if you add
more water or you start rinsing then the
concentration will decrease and you
might have less of this happening and
this is already getting pretty
complicated but it's still a massive
oversimplification because hairstyles
will not give us a break if you look at
the ingredients of almost any shampoo
it'll have three or more different
surfactants that means that these pink
tables in the diagram aren't all the
same if you change the ratio of the
ingredients or swap one of these out
with something else then the shampoo
might work quite differently plus
there's a bunch of other ingredients
that are shown here like polymers and
oils and those will also interact with
the surfactants and affect how it cleans
and on top of that things like the
texture of the shampoo the opening of
the bottle that's going to change how
much you dispense and how the shampoo
spreads on hair so in case you didn't
notice it is really complex and what
that means is trying to predict what
happens just by looking at whether some
of these pink tarpoles are sulfates or
not that is just not going to tell you
much it just isn't as simple as it has
sulfates it'll clean better or it'll
strip or degrease your hair if it was it
would be so much easier for everyone to
just find the right shampoo same with
the p Asia shampoos I see lots of people
saying you have to check the ph and make
sure it's acidic and again that is just
not a very meaningful piece of
information when the whole thing is so
complex it's a bit like trying to
predict how a food tastes from how
yellow it is and even if you knew the
full formula of a shampoo every single
ingredient what concentration they're in
where they got the ingredients it would
still be pretty much impossible to
predict how it's going to interact with
itself let alone with different types of
soils on your hair at different stages
of the shampooing process it takes a
ridiculous amount of computational power
to Model A much simpler sort of system
with way less moving Parts than a
shampoo this is why cosmetic formula to
spend so much time just during trial and
error making formulas and trying them
out changing little things about a
formula can make a huge difference
here's one example Good Housekeeping did
this test with 10 shampoo and
conditioner pairings that were meant to
protect color some of these are sulfates
and some didn't they were salon and
drugstore Brands the set that stripped
hair dye the least had sulfates it's
this tresemmator they also have this
article where hair scientists talk about
how complex it is to formulate a shampoo
but even with their own results as proof
and true scientists with phds explaining
to them that it's not about selfish
versus no sulfates their article on
color stripping and shampoos still has
this BS about sulfates starting the hair
and causing pigment loss these myths Run
Deep but I think a lot of us have had
the experience where we try a sulfate
free shampoo and it does feel like it's
gentle or it doesn't clean enough the
way you frame it probably depends on
whether or not your hair likes that and
the reason for this I think is a sort of
circular reasoning that happens quite a
bit with products formulators know that
people looking for sulfate free probably
want something that cleans less they
know there's all these widespread myths
about sulfates being harsh they've been
going around since the 90s like in this
email forward SLS is used to scrub
garage floors and it is very strong even
if the formulator didn't know about all
this because I don't know if they've
been hiding in a hole it's probably on
the product brief that's the description
of the product that the The formulator
Works off it's usually written by
marketing People based on consumer
research it'll have the marketing claims
that they plan to put on the products so
chances are the brief says sulfate free
as well as gentle and not stripping so
there's a good chance that if you grab a
random shampoo with sulfates and a
random shampoo without sulfates the one
with sulfates will clean better it's not
because just adding sulfates
automatically makes a shampoo strip more
we saw that it can be formulated to
strip color the least it's just because
of intentional product design the
formulator formulated with sulfates and
to make a clean more they might have
also changed some of the other
ingredients to make it feel like your
hair is cleaner but Brands don't all
have the same idea of what counts as
gentle and some Brands choose not to
follow this consumer Trend so there's
going to be lots of exceptions it's like
how if you grab a shampoo in a black and
green bottle there's a pretty good
chance it'll smell minty because product
designers have decided that is what men
like this is exactly the same situation
with foam and cleansers how well a
product Foams doesn't tell you about how
well it cleans what's happening on a
molecular level is different how well
something first depends on how well it
interacts with air how well it traps air
in a thin film cleaning is about how
well it interacts with oil and dirt both
cleaning and foam rely on surfactants
but apart from that there's no real
correlation between which surfactness
foam best and which ones clean best and
there's so much that depends on the
overall formula there are lots of other
ingredients that help to create a nice
foam again both are complicated
supramolecular processes there are so
many moving Parts but if something
doesn't foam when we use it we tend to
feel like it's not cleaning properly
it's a purely psychological thing and I
personally still have this gut feeling
even though I know all of this chemistry
behind it humans did not evolve to be
perfectly rational in our feelings so
formulators make sure that shampoos and
other cleaning products usually foam
really nicely for us but if we don't see
it then it doesn't have to foam to
convince us one example is detergents
for dishwashers they're actually kind of
formulated the opposite way they have to
clean really well with as little foam as
possible because foam causes pressure
pressure and if that builds up then it
can make the dishwasher leak and flat
out kitchen sploosh sploosh bottom line
selfie free sulfate containing doesn't
really mean much how well a shampoo
cleans is way too complicated to predict
that easily it's much more useful to
actually look at what the shampoo is
trying to tell you if it says clarifying
then it's a shampoo designed to clean
your hair better doesn't matter if it
has sulfates or not if it says color
protection it can have sulfates and
still strip dye less than a sulfate-free
shampoo if you stick to these rules
about sulfate versus sulfate free then
you would have missed out on the least
color stripping shampoo it's also really
useful to look at reviews from people
with similar hair to you and try it out
on your hair let me know what you
thought of this deep dive into hair
science what I should talk about next if
you enjoyed this video I would really
appreciate it if you gave it a thumbs up
and subscribe more nerdy hair science
videos are popping up around me now